l'objet de la contestation pour les
syndicats d'edf une fois ce projet
hercules nouvelle mobilisation devant
l'assemblée nationale afin de protester
contre ce projet qui engendrerait une
dislocation d'edf en plusieurs entités
pour pouvoir privatiser une partie d'edf
un accord qui aurait été à passer il y a
deux ans entre le gouvernement et
bruxelles un accord pointé du doigt par
les syndicats mais aussi par
l'opposition qui accuse l'exécutif
d'avoir fait passer en douce ce projet
hercules ce projet à hercules qui
engendra je vous le disais à une
dislocation en d'edf mais qui est
également entraînerait une rentabilité
beaucoup plus conséquente pour les
actifs privés et coûterait beaucoup plus
d'argent aux contribuables à plusieurs
élus politiques sont venus soutenir
cette mobilisation devant l'assemblée
nationale vous propose de les écouter
des reculs c'est le virus de la logique
d'actionnaires qui sont par du bien
commun de l'énergie et nous savons que
la conséquence directe de ça c'est
l'augmentation du prix pour l'usager
nous savons que l'homme quand la logique
d'actionnaires s'empare de l'énergie
alors on fait des économies sur la
maintenance sur la sous traitance sur la
sécurité sur les investissements des
réseaux mais c'est la mise à mort de ce
qui fait la notion de service public la
péréquation tarifaire face aux grands
défis qui sont devant nous nous avons
besoin d'un pôle public de l'énergie en
france donc on y voit l'occasion en
quelque sorte de dire stop
la concurrence qui devait baisser les
prix plus personne n'y croit tout le
monde voit que c'est l'effet inverse qui
s'est produit la concurrence qu'il veut
favoriser l'innovation
ça n'est pas vrai non plus donc ça
suffit maintenant on arrête les frais et
il faut dire aux français que tout cela
n'est fait toute cette casse d'un
fleuron comme edf
tout cela n'est fait que pour satisfaire
aux exigences de la commission
européenne on ne fait tout cela que pour
ça c'est surtout à une atteinte à
quelque chose qui a marché
on produit l'électricité la moins chère
décarbonés décarbonés et donc c'est
aujourd'hui il ya le lancement du projet
climatique et on va détruire l'outil qui
permet de faire des économies de carbone
mais faut être malade ce c'est très
grave pour moi c'est vraiment de la
haute trahison de l'intérêt national
il ya un intérêt stratégique national il
y a un intérêt est évidemment aussi pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
l'ensemble n'est pas patrimoine ses
cibles me semble-t-il comme n'importe
quel autre à savoir que ce projet et
recul pourrait engendrer une flambée des
prix de l'électricité
cette sixième journée de mobilisation a
été fortement suivie par les salariés
d'edf puisque un tiers et des effectifs
ont suivi ce mouvement de grève afin
d'interpeller le gouvernement sur ce
projet à coeur